foreign
[Music]
ly comes out on Tick Tock everything
happens
um pretty organically that's a
pink-haired Moe aiming to throw a pair
of fuchsia underwear in the garbage the
words if I miss I'm gay flash across the
screen as the singer fails to sink the
undies into the can
[Music]
oh
the video comes with no caption but fans
seem to think she's sending a message
about her sexuality one asks in the
comments did I just witness Madonna
coming out good for her well another
says we are witnessing her story this
comes just weeks after Madonna released
a remix of her 2005 hit hung up which
features lots of kisses with Dominican
rapper takisha
the song's new title hung up on tokisha
but steamy lip locks aren't just for the
cameras it feels good
Madonna and takisha have been smooching
all summer first at a pride event and
again while sitting front row at New
York Fashion Week when it comes to
Madonna's romantic history she's only
been linked to men she was even married
twice to Sean Penn in the 80s why break
the silence tonight why decide to come
out and Meet the Press
to see a great movie and decades later
in 2000 she tied the knot with filmmaker
guy Richie he's incredible life is still
exciting let's hope it continues to be
that way it's the first time we've been
out of the house since the wedding Flash
Forward to 2022 and it seems we'll get
more insight into madge's Life in Her
upcoming project I am making a movie
about my life so yep she's working on
her highly anticipated biopic and when
E.T spoke to madge's bestie Debbie Mazar
earlier this year she gave us some
insight on casting so I don't know who
my daughter's in a cast but Madonna is a
very talented she's very detail specific
and I think that she'll choose the right
person I said well they have to be a
little bit like this that and the other
thing because we go back since I'm 17
years old you know and um and I think
whoever plays me it's a juicy role we
had some great times and I'm just I'm
really proud of Madonna for you know
doing this to write it because I think
she's got a great Legend a great story
foreign